Italians have been probably going
stir-crazy for the last nine weeks with
that lockdown in Italy but of course now
on Monday it will finally start to ease
up meaning that many Italians will be
tasting freedom for the first time in a
very long time millions of workers are
due to set to go back to work but there
is confusion in Italy as to exactly what
the easing of restrictions will mean one
of the reasons is because the government
has announced a prescribed list of
things that people will now be able to
do but regional governments are able to
contradict that if they want to so for
example in some areas they say you can
go to the beach and enjoy the seaside
and other areas they see even if you
live on the beach you won't be able to
go to the beach and then the Italian
Prime Minister sort of confused things
even more by saying that Italians would
be able to go and see what he called the
consult a which is the Italian word for
kin many people turned around and said
well what does that means that mean I
can go and see my lover does that mean I
can go and see my friend prompting the
Italian Prime Minister's our office to
then issue a more clear understanding of
what exactly he was trying to say now
well many Italians are going to be very
happy to be going out in the streets
going back to work
there's also anger amongst small
businesses that haven't been included in
these easing of restrictions from Monday
in fact many bars won't be able to open
until at least the end of May and they
are very unhappy about that and actually
last week went into a protest in regards
that handing over the keys to their
shops and their bars to local officials
as part of that protest this is how
Giuseppe Conte the Italian Prime
Minister responded to that there is
disappointment among many economic
operators I understand them but to
restore the economic cycle of goods and
services that are less essential we need
customers to feel safe and protected
well the economic toll of the lock down
that nine weeks has been historic for
Italy I mean some of the figures show
that day Europe's third largest
economies expected to shrink by more
than any other year since the 1930s
since the Great Depression
now one poll has been trying to test the
waters of how Italians feel about the
next few months and this is what they
said and it makes pretty hard reading it
found that 50% feared that they will
lose their jobs over the next months
possibly the next year or so some 62%
are convinced that unemployment will
rise it could skyrocket in Italy and 57
percent so almost 6 out of 10 people are
pessimistic for the future so things may
be beginning to ease but it is clear
that many people are expecting there to
be a lot of bumps in the road over the
next few months and possibly years
you